Harry when you ask concern to people who
aren't particularly believers what they
love about Jesus what they often say is
they love the Sermon on the Mount that
the Sermon on the Mount tells us the
heart of the Christian gospel and they
may not know it but they love it
alright here's a surprising thing that
we come along and in Luke chapter 6
Jesus says very much what he seems to be
saying in the Sermon on the Mount but
he's saying it on a plane
PLA I am NOT air playing flat place
what's going on why these two different
versions and what's the difference
between them it's a really interesting
contrast with the Gospel of Matthew
where Jesus does speak from a mountain
reminds us in Matthew of Moses giving
the Torah on Mount Sinai and from
Matthew's point of view the continuity
between Jesus and Moses is very very
important
Luke also has his continuity with the
Old Testament but that's not one of them
my hunch is that both Matthew and Luke
had a source that gave an account of a
major sermon of Jesus that had a lot of
this material in it and each of them
frames this sermon in a way that's
compatible with his understanding of how
to tell the story of Jesus so Matt it's
Matthew I think who adds the the mount
theme okay and also adds some other
structuring elements to the story for
instance in Matthew's Sermon on the
Mount we have the antithesis of old it
was said but I tell you we don't have
that in okay now in Luke we we begin
with with the Beatitudes and that's
where Matthew begins as well but the
Beatitudes seem to function in two
different ways in these Gospels and it's
interesting to see to get Luke's profile
and to understand what's going on with
these these Beatitudes so and again the
contrast I think is a way to do so so in
Matthew you have blessed are the poor in
spirit which is the way I think of
suggesting a kind of attitude or
behavior you need to have a detachment
from worldly goods in Luke in the
Beatitudes you have a judgment on a
condition in Luke 6 chapter 20 blessed
are you who are really physically poor
yeah yours is the kingdom of heaven he
goes on blessed are you who are hungry
now for you will be filled not hungry
for righteousness but really hungry go
yeah so I think we have some continuity
here between
they sort of option for the poor theme
that we had in the Magnificat and the
Benedictus and that we had in jesus's
sermon quoting the prophecy of isaiah
there is a message of good news for the
poor here there's also interestingly
enough a message of judgment for the
rich and this continues the theme of the
mighty will be thrown down from there
and our high places and the like because
after the Beatitudes in Luke that we
have a series of woes which we don't
have in Matthew so Luke says but woe to
you who are rich for you have received
your consolation woe to you who are full
now for you will be hungry woe to you
who are laughing now for you will mourn
a very different prophetic tones now
what we have in Matthew so this this
form of beatitude wood or congratulatory
formula it works in different ways in
the two Gospels and probably picks up
two different emphases of what Jesus
actually did and taught I was gonna I
was gonna do this I'll do this once and
once only in our conversation today do
you have a guess on which comes closer
to the words of Jesus that we can get
those I think in general Luke is
probably a little closer to the original
wording of Jesus and a lot of the
material that he transmits that not
always and in some cases it's a very
tough call but I think overall this this
less artifice structuring of thanks and
so I have a hunch that Luke is picking
up a sayings tradition whether it's an
oral or written form that's closer to
the earliest phase of that transmission
well it's easier to see why Matthew
might want to tone it down a little bit
if you tell me that blessed are the poor
and I'm fairly wealthy that's annoying
if you say blessed are the poor in
spirit I think ah but I can do that
never even in my comfort and that's been
tougher on us in this way Luke is tough
who've already wrestled a little bit
with this issue of whom he is addressed
is it the poor or is it the rich and
I've suggested that I think he is
talking to a relatively well-to-do
Christian community and he has some
tough words from them on occasion yeah
your mighty them here yeah that they
stand on the judgment of Jesus that they
don't take their responsibilities
seriously but then it goes on the the
rest of the Sermon on the
the plane in Luke has a lot of material
that we find also on the Sermon on the
Mount in Matthew including the love
command loving enemies is a hallmark of
this ethos of Jesus and non-violence
they turn the other cheek is also there
in Luke 629 and generosity give to
anyone who asks something that I find
hard to do sometimes but they the love
command and all with all of its its
force its bite is here and in Luke and
that certainly is central today and they
message of Jesus but at the end we have
a little bit of lucan shaping to in Luke
636 in a position where in Matthews
version of the great sermon we have the
saying be perfect as your heavenly
Father is perfect we have Luke
portraying Jesus as saying be merciful
just as your father is merciful now this
may reflect two different translations
of some Aramaic phrase or it may reflect
a kind of theological difference
perfection I think for Matthew is
righteousness adherence to the the Torah
as Jesus and observers to interpret says
right for Luke it's this vertices in a
huge mercy that was highlighted in the
Magnificat mercy that's going to be
highlighted and it's constantly and
Jesus's interaction of mercy on the
cross that's right that's one theme one
story that we have in here that's only
in Luke is in chapter 11 where Jesus
raises a widow's son
you mean chapter 7 I mean in chapter 7
chapter 7 verse 11 where you just raises
a woman's son I want to say two words
about that before we get to the parable
yeah it's one of three stories of
resurrection that we have in the Gospels
and in each of these cases I think what
we have is a foretaste of what happens
to Jesus in his final vindication or
that's crystal clear and they at the
fourth gospel with the raising of
Lazarus here it's early on and it's
interesting that's framed in terms of a
widow's son
part of this Lucan theme of come
passion toward women in particular and
another example of God's mercy toward
toward all of Israel but another woman
that's right where a woman comes she's
invited you to the banquet she pulls
takes down her hair hairs taken down she
wipes Jesus feet people say this guy's a
prophet why couldn't you know she was a
sinner and Jesus tells a little story
about the sin and forgiveness sounds
like I've had a paradigm of what looks
up to in some way absolutely this is
Luke chapter 7 verse 36 and following
and it's a story that's that's
replicated in the Gospel of John chapter
12 where the woman has identified as
Mary Mary of Bethany and later church
tradition will complete that Mary with
Mary Magdalene Mary Magdalene who by the
way is mentioned in Luke chapter 8 as
one of the women who support the mission
of Jesus Mary from whom seven demons
hair but it's not explicit that the
woman in chapter seven is Mary Magdalene
so what we have is a sinful woman
marginalized probably rejected by the
Pharisaic establishment the house in
which Jesus is eating his own by a
Pharisee according to 736 and Jesus
insists that an essential part of his
gospel is outreach to people even like
this you know when luke is telling the
story he might well be telling it within
an environment where the issue of the
possibility of forgiveness for post
baptismal sin especially serious sexual
sin is on the table we know that that
was a serious issue in the second
century in the church and I think Luke
is is insisting that the the message of
Jesus is the message of radical
compassion and forgiveness even for the
most serious of sins perfect so this
becomes a way in which once again in
Jesus God's grace reaches that God's
mercy reaches out to use Luke's language
far beyond the boundaries of what we
would usually expect yes indeed it's a
exemplary of the whole just and that
sense very powerful thank you